[Music]
so Pete Super Mario run finally came out
you've been playing it for quite a bit
already is this the mobile Mario
experience you were expecting uh sort of
I mean we were shown a glimpse of the
game and I understood this is a
persistent runner not an endless runner
because you do have you know distinct
levels that you are completing is Mario
and you know it looks like the new super
mario brothers games mario has a lot of
different animations and with just one
little press of the screen depending on
where he is relation to the ground or in
the air enemies he can do a lot of
different animations so it does kind of
feel like a a Mario game and maybe
unlike what we've seen in iOS before
because it is such an iconic franchise
but at the same time I've played the
game for a few hours and I've I've
already beat all the levels in the game
so what I'm left with is something that
I didn't really expect which is this
sort of Kingdom building aspect hmm and
so let's start with how this game
actually feels because you know at first
blush you a mentioning it's just one
button tab miski that those are the only
controls in the game you know does it
get any more complex than that doesn't
feel like you know you Mario's full
arsenal moves or actually within this
game no I mean I as far as I can tell
there aren't any like you're not getting
a fireball you're not getting wings to
like fly in the air you're basically
jumping jumping off of walls and what's
a little bit interesting is that you
don't always have to jump on an enemy's
head for example something that's
typical the Mario series that so many
other games have played off of a small
enemy if you just let Mario
automatically run into it it will he
will vault right over them so yes it
feels like Mario but it's also very
different I mean it's it's certainly not
a one to one example of Mario game play
you're making it sound pretty easy that
like is it actually easy I mean if you
just run out of Goomba you're just gonna
jump over them automatically as our
incorrect the game is pretty easy at
large there are some stages that put you
in like the haunted house for example so
there you the rooms are sort of static
it's not scrolling automatically but
like the original Mario Brothers when
you run off one side of the screen you
end up coming out of the other and so
there are these small little puzzle
challenges that you have to navigate
while avoiding the ghosts we
we'll follow Mario automatically and you
can defeat them but it's not that easy
you have to sort of jump and spin on to
them but again the controls are sort of
contextual so if the timing isn't
perfect you might end up dying outside
of those scenarios the game is pretty
easy like I said it took less than two
hours to beat every level so where's the
challenge in it then the challenge in it
is perseverance because there are things
that you can unlock including extra
characters there's obviously Mario that
you start with when you beat the game
you get Princess Peach there's also
Yoshi Luigi and toad I believe I'm
target and Toadette so to get these
characters you need to go into the My
Kingdom portion of the game which as you
pointed out is sort of similar to neko
atsume the you know the popular Japanese
mobile game where you populate a room
and attract cats or some area and
attract cats this is very similar
premise you are trying to attract toads
so with the coins you earn in the game
you purchase you know buildings little
pieces of like scenery to place and
that's where your toads live but the
toads you actually get by racing
opponents like the ghosts of these
opponents that have been uploaded online
and you should try to collect more coins
in them and there is like a virtual
audience of toads watching you and so
you have to impress them by getting more
coins and pulling off moves and this is
the toad rally section of the game right
where it seems like that's where it's
trying to give you that longevity right
because you can go in there and
basically it's a score attack time
attack against like a ghost opponent yes
but you can't do it just endlessly you
have to spend what are called I think
rally tickets toad rally tickets and you
know first I should say that you have to
buy this game if you want to play all
the levels in Super Mario run you have
to pay ten dollars because after the
third stage the game basically says you
cannot play until you give us ten bucks
so it's free to download right we get
three stages and then bam timber free to
start so when you pay that ten bucks you
also get some in-game item gifts which
include these toad rally tickets once
you expend all of those the only way to
get them again i believe is through
replaying old courses but but also you
have these gift boxes that appear and
you have a bonus house in the mike
Kingdom every eight hours you can play a
level where you have a chance to get a
tote rally ticket so it's sort of
unclear to me right now because I have
so many to rally tickets and I'm just
sort of you know beginning to build my
kingdom out what it's going to feel like
when I run out and if I will want to
keep playing this game it sounds like
it's really tried to incorporate some of
those mobile games tough aspects where
you know you have to try and you know
and currency and you know you know have
this sort of like forced time period on
YouTube to wait does it does it feel
more like a mobile game or a mario game
that has some mobile elements in it oh
that's a great question it's a it's a
mobile game first because you do really
you can blow through the domain levels
really fast and in those moments you
feel like you're playing a mario game
but the adventure ends so quickly and
your pursuits are then driven by these
very non Mario things which is building
out a kingdom and really I think that's
not Mario in most people's eyes that is
sort of more of a mobile game where you
are trying to like you said be motivated
by the addition of new little things to
keep playing but you're replaying the
same content for the most part which is
very unmarked Oleg so who is this game
for like if you have been a dialogue
mara fan waiting for a new mario game to
come out it is this going to be a game
you should download shred work that's a
very difficult question I'm someone who
has kept up with Mario for the last 30
years and I immediately felt like this
is a fun little experience but I don't
didn't want to pay ten bucks for it you
know I did because I need to play the
whole game but when I know that I have
all these other Mario experiences
available that look the same and
actually give me more control and more
stuff to explore I'm actually more
motivated by this to go play those games
on my new 3ds or on my wii u or we but i
think if you play a lot of games on your
phone and you are a long time mario fan
like me i don't play a lot of games my
phone but if you're if you're really
ingrained in that sort of mentality and
habit i think you'll like this i think
you'll find something there that sort of
you know it's that same cycle that that
feedback loop that a lot of mobile games
give you and it's in a really charming
Mario / Nintendo package it's it's hard
not to be charmed by what you see well
thanks for that Peter super my run i
think is app globally right now
on iOS
[Music]